problem number 15
15.
and we have two triangles so let's see
we have one triangle here
one triangle like this
we have another triangle that looks
fairly similar
i don't know if they actually are
similar i haven't read the problem yet
at least in the drawing they've drawn
them to look fairly similar
and then they tell us that so this is
triangle
a
b
c
this is triangle d e f
d
e
f and we know this is eight this is five
this is x degrees
this is also x degrees
this is
five
and then they tell us that this is
y degrees this is
y degrees now let's read the problem if
y
if y is equal to 60 in triangle def
above
how much greater is the perimeter of a b
c than the perimeter of d e f
so y is equal to 60 right
so y is equal to 60.
y is equal to 60.
so what is
this angle up here
well if we know these are these two are
are the the base angles well
actually we we know 60 60 so what's this
top angle going to be well this is an
equilateral triangle right this also has
to be equal to 60. i mean brain's not
malfunctioning so this is if all the
angles are same then all the sides are
the same as well right
that's 5
and 5. that's an equilateral triangle
and then the perimeter
is 5 plus 5 plus 5 is 15.
this problem
we know these we don't know the x angles
but we know that they're equal so if
they're if these two base angles are
equal we know from geometry class that
of course the sides are also equal
so this side is eight this side is also
eight
so the perimeter here is what 8 plus 8
is 16
plus 5 is 21 and they want to know how
much greater is the perimeter of this
triangle than this triangle so 21 minus
15 is 6.
and that is choice
c
next problem
right yeah choice c
problem number 16.
if x and y are positive consecutive odd
integers positive consecutive odd
integers
where y is greater than x positive
consecutive odd integers which of the
following is equal to
y squared
minus
x squared
so x and y are positive consecutive odd
integers
and y is greater than x so that means
that y
is equal to x plus what it's equal to x
plus 2.
if they were consecutive just integers
then y would be equal to x plus one it
would be one more than x but since we
know that they're both odd
and y is the next larger odd number the
distance between any two odd numbers is
two so x is going to be two more and y
is going to be two more than x right if
x is five
then y is seven right consecutive odd
integers if x is three y is five
consecutive odd integers y is two more
than x so we know y is equal to x plus
two and so they want us to kind of
rewrite this expression well we know
from algebra class we can factor this as
y
plus x
times y
minus x
right
and then what is
what is y
plus x actually we don't even have to do
this we don't even have to factor it we
know what y is equal to right y is equal
to x plus 2 so that is equal to x plus 2
squared minus x squared
and this is equal to if we just multiply
it out x squared plus 4x
plus 4
that's this term and now we minus x
squared
so this cancels out with this and we're
left with 4x
plus 4 which is choice e
whenever i see something like this my
first temptation is to factor it out and
i think that's what they and you could
have done it and then you could
substitute it back in but you didn't
even have to do that
image clear image
invert colors
it's actually 6 30 in the morning after
thanksgiving you gotta appreciate my
discipline
all right problem number number 17.
my wife's actually a medical resident
and she had to work 36 hours yesterday
and then she came home essentially
passed out missed thanksgiving
everything and then she just went to
work again and she has like a 12-hour
shift it's crazy she only has a year
left and i i look forward to that but
there might be fewer math videos once
i have my wife back but anyway back to
math problem number 17. in the x y plane
line l passes through the origin and is
perpendicular to the line 4. so l is
perpendicular to the line 4
x
plus
y
is equal to k
and l passes through the origin so
through origin
through
zero zero that's the origin right
where k is a constant if the two lines
intersect at the point
t
t plus 1
what is the value of t
so first of all we know this line is
perpendicular to this line
so what does perpendicular tell us
perpendicular says whatever the slope is
of this line the perpendicular of this
line sorry whatever the slope is of this
line the slope of this line would be the
negative inverse
so let's figure out what the slope of
this line is so we know that 4
x plus y is equal to k
so y is equal to minus 4 x plus k now
this is kind of the familiar you know y
equals mx plus b
format right so the slope of this line
is -4 slope
equals minus 4.
so the slope of this line is -4 so what
is the slope of l slope
of l
equals well l is perpendicular to this
line it's perpendicular to this line so
we know that l is going to have the
negative inverse of this slope so the
negative inverse of minus 4 is well
it'll become positive and you take the
universe the slope of l is one-fourth
and we also know that l goes through
the origin so it's
its y-intercept is zero right so we know
the equation of l right we know that we
know that the equation of l is y is
equal to
1 4
x and we know there's no plus b because
it goes up through 0 0 right and you
could even i mean if you didn't believe
me you can
put 0 0 in here and then solve for b
you'll get 0 equals 0 plus b so b is 0.
anyway so this is l
we've solved for the equation for l
and now they tell us
they tell us that we intersect
where's the problem i lost track of the
page oh we intersect at the point t t
plus one and they want to figure out
what t is
so when x is t y is t plus one so let's
see when x is so y is t plus one so
t
plus one is equal to
one 4
and then x is t right
x is t i just substituted t and t plus 1
for x and y
and now we just solve let's see if we
subtract 1 4 t from both sides let me do
finish this problem up here
up here we subtract 1 4 t from both
sides we get
3 4 t
plus 1 is equal to 0 right i just
subtracted 1 4 t from this 1t so you get
3 4 t
and subtract 1 from both sides you get 3
4 t
is equal to minus 1 and then you just
multiply both sides times the inverse
four thirds
four thirds so t this cancels out of
course t is equal to minus 4 over 3.
and
what is my choice there oh there i go
choice number a
i got scared i looked at the wrong
problem i didn't see my choice maybe i
did it wrong choice number a and i will
do problem 18 in the next video i'll see
you soon